in the five year history of the
Sinquefield Cup why do you think it is
we have not seen a repeat winner
everyone's really hungry everyone wants
to do well and if the players are in a
in a good sort of fighting mood then I
think you have a lot of decisive results
the level is really high and everyone
wants to play interesting shots and so
that's why we've had so many different
winners second thing if in the middle of
the year there's some played quite a bit
of tournaments we're not in the freshest
state I think that that shows how good
is a tournament because if it will be so
easy to win the Mongoose will win it if
you ask me five years ago
muggins will win two times five five C
of course even winning of course Magnus
is the best clearly but still there is a
fight in every tournament so so maybe
this here is Luke just somebody will
will repeat the victory for a long time
Magnus was dominating at the top but
he's not winning every tournament and
recently he hasn't been in been winning
as much as before but it does show that
everyone's bringing their best chess
here and you know it's not gonna be easy
for anyone
generally of course Magnus should have
had more chances but I don't recall him
having such good tournaments here the
only time he won was because I'd
wondered to her terribly in a situation
where I could have won two tournaments
so we'll see how this time comes down to
who is in the best shape at the moment
so I think that explains a lot
also the fact that you know there is a
lot of doctress players who are very
close in level I think you think they'll
cup everyone you know wants to do very
well because wrecking field is really
the only patron chef in America if
everyone wants to show their best foot
forward I think it's a very competitive
event just top 10 players and you know
it's so strong very often comes down to
the last two days